[拍手]
はいどうもこんにちは金高大輔と申します
私はチーム件4件力も名誉も
バナーならも好感度も何も持ってないん
ですけどもあの私あのだから何も境地と
伝えれる事ないんじゃないかなーって思っ
たんですけどただまあそう言ってしまうと
大変安の刺客を開いいただいたのに失礼だ
なと思いまして私が大切にしている考え方
そしてこの考え方をしたことによって私の
人生は非常に豊かになったので少しだけ
そんな考え方について皆様に共有ができ
たらなと思いますまず前提なんですが私
自分にまったく耳新がありませんなかなか
堂々と話ししてるかも知れないですけど
自信が全くなくてですね
でかつ
まあ何をやっても失敗をしてでまぁ何を
やっても人に迷惑をかける
まあそんなずに人生をずっと今32年間を
送ってるんですけどその中でこの本当に
自分って迷惑ばかりかけてるんだなーって
実感したのが14歳です
14歳といったら中学校2年生ぐらいなん
ですけど私4人きょうだいの末っ子でして
バニーがいるんですがその兄がですね14
歳の頃
非常に心を病んでおりましてその病んで
いる兄に対して私全く気付くことができ
なくてひたすらおそらく傷つけていたん
ですねで学校に通ったらすごく仲良かった
友達たちが一戦いい僕のことをいじめて
くるという経験をしましてそうなった時に
学校に行ったら友達からいじめられて家に
帰ったら僕が人を傷つけているっていうの
を実感したときに
僕生きている意味ないなと早く死んだ方が
いいんじゃないかなってで強く思いました
それから僕ずっと
人生
死にたいなぁって思う日々はここから
始まっていくんですけど
じゃあその
僕の中で生まれたのがなんで僕は死にたい
って言いながら
死なないんだろうかっていう問いが生まれ
たんですねでで本当に知りたかったら
そもそもまで[ __ ]ばいいと思うんですけど
僕は知らないんですよ死にたいっていう
だけでじゃなんで僕死にたいというだけで
死なないんだろうなぁって問いを考えたら
気に
臆病者なのかなっ
思ったんですけどなんかを死ぬの木秒もの
かもしれないしとかっていろいろ考えた時
に
死にたいって思って言っているだけの人
って実は
いきたいって思えているから死にたいって
言ってるんじゃないかなって思ったんです
もっと言えば生きる意味がわかれば死にた
いって思わないんじゃないかな
って思ったんです
他にも
僕には価値がない
ぼくよりぼくのことが嫌いな人はこの世界
には絶対に存在しない僕が一番最悪だと
思ってたんですけどこれも
一つ逆にしてみると
僕以来にはめちゃくちゃ価値があ
るっていう
もっと言えばこんなに価値のない僕と一緒
にいてくれる人たちまた会いたいと言って
くれる人達ってなんて素敵な人たちなん
だろうな
この人たちに
何か恩返しがしたい
すごい感謝の気持ちが生まれたんですよね
そうなっていくうちにしすごく最初
ネガティブなスタートだったかもしれない
ですけど
だんだん自分の気持ちが豊かになっている
のも実感してきました
ここで共通するものとしても先ず一つ自分
が感じているものを磨いとしてとらえたと
いうことともう一つがいろんな角度で反対
逆いろんな角度で見てみるっていうのが今
のエピソードに共通することですもう一つ
成功したいな
失敗したくないな
めっちゃ思います皆さんも思うんじゃない
かなって思うんですけど
成功したいな失敗したくないなぁと思っ
たら
いや
もっと失敗しようというふうに考えるよう
に僕はしていますそうすることによって何
が起きるかというともちろん失敗したら
傷ついたり苦しんだりもするんですけど
ただ失敗いっぱいするとその分だけ人生が
楽しくなって最終的に成功した時
めちゃめちゃ楽しい
すげー輝かしい失敗がこの成功につながる
なって思うんですよねもちろんこれ
いっぱい失敗したいっていうのは同じ失敗
をしても面白くないです
いろんな失敗をしたいんですいろんな失敗
するためにはめちゃくちゃいい方法がある
んですよ新しいことをするっていう新しい
ことに挑戦すると絶対失敗するんですよ
ってなると
あ
すげー人生楽しくなってるって感じられて
ああ
そのときにこの失敗してもこのくじけずに
いい感じがいま人生漆芸楽しくなっている
と
で最終的に失敗のない成功は人生の失敗
だって思えるとめちゃめちゃポジティブに
いろんなものに挑戦できるようになるって
有用な人生になってきました
ここで共通していることも
まず
表自分が捉えられる目に見えるところ表だ
としたときにこれを磨いとして捉えると
その同時に裏っかわ
にも
同じ何か他の価値が生まれているんじゃ
ないかなっていうことですこれはもう
プラスでもマイナスのでもです
改めてですが
まず問いを立てる
問いを立てたらそれをいろんな角度から見
てみるそしてこれを俯瞰しながらも同時に
はオモテウラを同時に見ることができない
ので交互にしっかりと実感を持って見て
みるっていう思考法のことを置くは両義的
思考と名付けました
今日はですね一つ
あの皆さんと共通するテーマに関して両義
的思考何考えてみたいと思いますその
テーマというのは
便利さです
便利さって聞いて言い合いや私便利さいら
ないですといやもう便利さなどほんと嫌い
って言う人いないと思うんですよね
その中でじゃあこの僕も名義と不便どっち
がいいですかって言ったら絶対に便利を
選ぶんですけど
じゃあ
便利さの両義的な反対側また裏っかわ
いろんな角度で見たときに何が実は生まれ
ているのかなと同時にっていうのを一緒に
考えたいと思います
私は便利さの反対
単純に考えたら不便さですけど実は私不便
さじゃなくて
不寛容が生まれているんじゃないかなと
そしてもう一つ
便利になっていくこれもとても素晴らしい
事なんですが便利になればなるほど私たち
は何が起きるかというと省略された過程が
わからなくなるんじゃないかなと
ただこれ着ないポンポンと言われてどう
いうことってなるんでもう少し具体的にお
話ししたいと思います
例えば水です
私たち生きる上で水絶対に必要ですよね
みずいらないよって1人ないと思うんです
よその中でじゃあ絶対に必要な水なんです
移動日なったら水が出ますコンビニに行っ
たら水が簡単に買えます
ただ
急に水道などが払ってたとしても急に水道
が水が出なくなったよと
またはコンビニに行ったら水が売ってい
ないおいていないという状態になったら皆
さんいかがでしょう
なんでーっていう水でないんですけど
やばいんですけどってならないですかね
コンビニに行っても本当に水かいたんです
けど
水変えないと
でそのいらいらー誰だれなの悪いの自治体
みたいないろいろ出てくるんですよね
家庭に関してもそんなに大切な水なら
そんなに大切な水を出してくれる水道を
自分で治せる必要ありますよねほんとはで
も治せない
本日の水だって本当だった水本当に大切
なら
もしなくなったとしても十分で水を作れ
たり取りに行けるっていうその過程を知っ
ているという家から絶対に必要ですよねで
もどこの誰かも分からない人にそれを依存
している依存しているから僕たちに何が
生まれるかといったらああああああ不安が
生まれるんじゃないかと
不安が生まれたことによってこの不安が
イライラになったりいろんな物にぶつかっ
てくるんじゃないかなと
じゃあ今私たちこの生活の中でこの不安
解消するために何してるかって言ったら
おそらく
お金を稼ぐことじゃないかなって思います
お金を稼ぐとある程度この不安を解消さ
れるんですよ何か良いいざとなった時の
ために水買った公みたいなんだか私ある
程度お金持ってるから優先的に直して
もらおうとか分からないですけどただ本当
に水が止まってコンビニにも水がない
ってなった場合お金どのくらい必要ですか
どんだけ持っててもこの不安
きえなくないですか
そう考えたときに
改めて
便利さってじゃあそもそも僕たちなんで
便利の世界を求めてたんだろうな
考えた時に
おそらく余った時間を作ってその余った
時間を有意義に過ごしたいなぁと思った
から電離さを求めたんじゃないかなと思う
んですよ
じゃあその余った時間なんていうかといっ
たら
暇
いとまです
で実はこの概念って日本語日本人が作った
わけではなくてすごく昔からありますどの
くらいあるかといったらギリシャの時代
からありますギリシャの時代に
アリストテレスはこの糸満のことを
スコレーと呼んで事故の充実に充てられる
最も贅沢な時間
それを位となって読んでたんですよねで
芸者の時代だったらそれ奴隷を使って
わざわざ無理やり作り出してで色んな
楽しい事をやってたんですけど今って
めちゃくちゃ便利じゃないですか
めちゃくちゃ便利になってるから
めちゃくちゃ伊藤正あるはずなんですけど
皆さん伊藤まあります
あったとしてもそのいとま
大切にしているでしょうか
気づいたらスマホ触ってなんとなーくこの
暇な時間するしてまた忙しい時間に戻って
いく
こんな生活を送っているんじゃないかなと
思います
ただですね今日改めてなんですがこの
いとま本来の意味の有意義に過ごしていく
ための遑っていうのに人間にとって必要な
要素って何なのかなじゃあ僕たちこの
いとまを手に入れるためには何が必要なの
かなって考えたときにこれは私が考えたん
ですが
it まが必要なんじゃないかなと
これうまいこと言ってるんですねこれ
うまいこと言ってるんですけど
info on 後には胃という感じとま
という漢字を使う言葉たくさんあります皆
さんも多分想像できると思います
じゃあどんなものがあるかといったら
いいだったら意識と石徳意味
まであれば時間空間仲間
今僕がこれだしたのは適当に出しただけで
はなくて人間にとって絶対に必要な
いとまを作り出すための it 待って何
かなって考えたときに今の6つなんじゃ
ないかなとしかももっと言えばこのいとま
の捉え方または感じ方の違いが人間性の
違いなんじゃないかなって思ったんです
ちょっと飛躍したのでもう少し分かり
やすくを説明しますと
一とまというのはこの6つの要素があり
ますよと話ししたんですが例えばですよ
意味っていうところを捉えた上でもただ犬
って聞いたら皆さんいいのはわかりますよ
ねただ犬って聞いたら可愛いと思う人と怖
いって思う人がいるこれ絶対ますよね
きっと
同じ意味だとしてもその捉え方によって人
によってその人間性が変わってくる
別にそれが良いか悪いかということでは
なく
例えば時間に関してもすごく好きな人と
嫌いな人といる1時間同じ1時間だとして
もそのおそらくその1時間って感じ方全然
違うんですよね
手順を考えたときにあこの6つの要素お暇
の違いっていうのが人間性の違いになって
くるんじゃないかなと思ったんですが
もう1回話戻しますと
便利さっていうのは何を
産んでる何をどうしているかと言うと
いとまを省略する行為なのかもしれないな
と言い換えれば
人間性を省略することが便利さなんじゃ
ないかなっていうことです
どういうことかといったら意識石井3空間
時間仲間
なくても私たちが生きるための一食住
スマホひとつで手に入りますよ仲間なんて
いなくて昔ロトは仲間いなかったら食料手
に入らないかもしれないですけど今スマホ
ひとつで手に入るんですよ
人間性入らないんですよ
っていうのを考えた時にもちろんここは私
便利さを否定しているわけでも人間性を
ただただ肯定しているわけでもないです
こう人間性があることによって非常に
めんどくさいことたくさんあると思います
ただ事実としてこういうことが起きてない
かってことなんです
そして
改めて提案したいのがもちろん便利さって
必要だよねと言う上で
1等マン
もう一緒に実感できる大切にできるだとし
たらそんな社会ってめっちゃ素敵なんじゃ
ないかなとこの2つを実現できるのが今の
現代で人間性をより豊かに実感できる社会
なんじゃないかなとそういうことです
じゃあ
今あなた何やってるのって言われましたら
私はですね
こういう場所を作ってましてここは
もともと耕作放棄地で野菜が育たなくなっ
てしまってずっと放置された場所なんです
けど今ここで無農薬無肥料
肥料も自分では与えることなく
なんなら今年に関しては水も挙げてない
です
水もあげずに今年めちゃめちゃ野菜でき
ましたッパなぜならいろんな虫といろんな
植物といっしょ所に共存させて生物多様性
というものをしっかりと実感を通してまぁ
作って言っている場所なんですけど
この場所でただこのこれ白いどうもこれ土
だけでできてるんですけど
この自分たちの衣食住っていうのをつくら
れていく過程ってなんとなくなら大工さん
が作りおねっとかっていろいろわかるん
ですけどその過程自体をいろんな生物の
つながりの中でできてるんだって言うこの
いとまを感じられるような授業がやるい
たいなと思ってこの耕作放棄地だった
ところを今研修施設というか学校や
いろんな社会人の人たちに伝える場所とし
て今場所づくりをしています
具体的にもまあいろんな
ところから学生が来てくれて先月は
だいたい1500人くらい来てくれました
まあ社会人から学生もあれいろんな人たち
にいろんないっとーまを感じてもらえる
自分は何が本当に好きなんだっていうのを
気づいてもらえるような場所をつくって
いるということです
そして最後に私がこの両義的思考の中で
非常に大切にしているメッセージを
を伝えてきたのだと思います
私が変わっても世界は変わらない
おそらく一度ぐらい人生でこれは考えた
ことがあるんじゃないかなと思うんですが
私も考えたことがありますまあ私は変わっ
たところで世界変わんないようなと今社会
課題いっぱいあるけどまぁいうて私なんて
いって思うんですがこれ両義的思考で
ちゃんと捉えるとどうなるのか私が見て
いる世界というのは間違い学私しか見れ
ない世界なんですよね私しか捉えられて
ないこのいとまがあるので私しか見てない
世界なんですけど私しか見られない世界と
いうことはその世界を変えられるのは私
しかいないっていうことなんですよ
もっと言えば私が変われば世界は変わるか
もしれないかもしれない絶対変わるとは
言わないですただかもしれない
って考えるとじゃあ世界を変えたいなら
絶対に私が変わらざるを得ない私は変わろ
うって思えるんじゃないかなっていうこと
ですそしてもう一つじゃあ私が変われもう
本気だして代わってどのくらい世界に影響
が与えられるかっていうのを考えたときに
いいいやこれ2人ぐらいだったら人生かけ
てですよ人生かけて2人ぐらいだったら
加速なり友達ない誰でもいいですけど
巻き込めるんじゃないかな
これだったら結構思えるかもしれないです
そんなインフルエンザとかでもなくても
ただこの2人に影響が与えられるんだとし
たら世界を変えるかもしれないんです
どういうことかといったら二人に伝えて
その二人がまた2人に伝えていくこれを
33回繰り返します2-33条です
美濃三十三条ってどういう数字かって言っ
たら
85億を超える数字になります
85送ってどういう数字かって言ったら
2030年の時の世界の人口です
一人が二人に伝えてっていうのを33回
繰り返したら世界全員つながるんですよ
汽笛ですねこれ
ちなみにこの2030年
どんな年かというと誰一人取り残さない
世界という sdg ずという
呼ばれているまあものの達成目標の最後の
年です
誰一人取り残さない世界をつくるのぜって
めっちゃむずいなと思い思います僕も行っ
ちゃうまず1人も録り逃さないですごいね
やっている
ただ
今言ったように1人が2連室内でこう33
回繰り返しただけで世界全員つながるんだ
としたらそんなつながり作ってみたい
なーって思うんですよね
そして私なりにこの言葉を言い帰るんだと
したら
一人一人にいとまがある世界私は世界共通
に何かこれが正しいよっていう考え方をお
伝えすることは絶対にできないですなぜ
なら僕の正しさと皆さんのちょっと鼻先と
違うし
って考えたときに
最後に皆さんにお伝えしたいのは
何か正解一つっていうのを決めずにそれを
何か捉えたらそれを解いとして捉えて両義
的思考じゃどっちもあるよな
なるほどって考える思考をしていただける
とその思考の中にはきっと
1トンまが生まれていると思いますしそう
やって捉えられる時間がある人たちは
おそらくいとまがあるんじゃないかなと
思うので是非
そういった気持ちを持って両義的思考を
もって最もある世界を一緒に作っていけ
たらなと思っております
はい以上になりますありがとうございまし
た
[拍手]